taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
how you taste buddies it's the taste
buds podcast i'm joe i'm salvatore
volcano
derosa joe derosa
this is my friend joe derosa by the bye
uh not sure if this episode has come out
yet but we did do a battle of buffalo
wing versus mozzarella stick
in which joe took buffalo and wing and i
took mozzarella stick i just want to let
our listeners know
that right after that episode we walked
downstairs and joe had a mozzarella
stick
it was delicious nice cheese that much
saying who won what just saying that
right you went you were battling against
it and then you went downstairs and had
one you've battled against foods that
you enjoy
yeah but i haven't um didn't immediately
start chewing on them post
haste what do you want for me big
surprise the only thing to eat at your
house is the food you were defending
i was hungry i'd eat something i just
have cabinets of mozzarella
well today we're shifting towards sugary
treats
we've had this one on the burner for a
while i
for a while have been uh saying that i
i've been wanting to fight sal
on and represent team sour patch kids
for a long time
uh i've repeatedly brought it up in fact
the other day i was walking through
manhattan
and i texted you a picture of the sour
patch kids store
a brick-and-mortar stand-alone sour
patch kids store
yeah which i can't believe exists that's
like saying
by the way that really blew my mind
because pick any other candy besides
eminem's who have their own stores
um which is more amazing or in hershey's
brand or her hershey's more of like
no but big umbrella specific singular
candy that'd be like saying like come to
the
starburst to the skittle store maybe to
the skittle store
for instance um so here's the thing i'm
not a huge candy guy right
but um but i i you know i dabble and
joe just keeps pushing me i will take
you on with sour patch kids against
anything you got
and so i've been putting it off because
i i'm not a staunch
advocate of of candy the reason why
i felt so passionate about that is
because i said to you once
sour patch kids are the greatest candy
of all time and you said you're out of
your mind
you are out of your mind so i ever since
then
i nobody would agree with that only
nobody would agree all the time start
talking when you have nerds generalities
you have nerds you have pez you have
skittles you have starburst
you have spree you have you just say pez
as the greatest candy over sour patch
kids
i would take pez over salad but i would
take pez
take the toy out of the equation with
pets no just always part of it just
no no take the toy out of the equation
i'm talking just the flavor of that
candy
you put pez against a sour patch well i
don't like sour patch kids at the stands
and i think you're gonna find that it's
a polarizing candy and not all the
people love
to be kicked in the throat and mouth and
tongue with sour
but they got their own store pesticides
i collect pests i think pes does have
its own store somewhere the thing about
pets
i gotta argue if i'm arguing pez i'm not
gonna argue pez has the whole package of
pez
i understand that but that's that's not
fair that's not fair
you're bringing a toy contraption into
the mix but that is
how it is marketed and sold that is the
container
for the pez it's an experience i'm just
talking the candy in and of itself i
will digra i would i
back off i won't that's controversial
right now i could see the argument going
either way
listen i collected pez dispensers for
years
i still have mine so do i should trade
sometime you want to do it you want to
do it on what is doing on the podcast i
was just going to say
maybe that'd be a fun they're probably
in my mom's attic i'll find them we're
talking about doing a live youtube
show that might be a fun youtube as we
bring in all our pits
let's do that yeah i love that yeah i'm
not gonna i mean pez is the greatest
candy of all time if you if you talk
about the dispenser
yes of course there's nothing more fun
than pulling
a cherry lozenge out of a superhero's
throat i love it
yeah you talk about a candy that stood
the test of time our kids today
little kids toddlers tykes and so on and
so forth
are they still as excited about pez and
pez dispensary
as we were when we were younger are kids
collecting them i don't they up to snuff
i don't think so uh oh let's just say
between them
two occasions 70 million dispensers you
have to read it joe like you're reading
it to the audience
you can't read it like you're thumbing
through something on the subject can i
can i be amazing
i'm trying billions i'm just trying to
70 million dispensers and five billion
candies per year are distributed
pes products are available in more than
80 countries worldwide
i mean i feel like they'd be big in
japan acronym
what does pez stand for where did the
word pez come from
what does pez stand for let's see is an
abbreviation of
what what holy [ __ ]
the name pez is an abbreviation of
peppermints
which is german for peppermint
i just blew my own balls off
[Music]
[Laughter]
right now original product i have none a
round peppermint
lozenge called pes drops jesus god
talk about a food product that took a
turn for the better
that's the god almighty that sounds
harsh can i
uh can i indulge you in a peppermint
uh a round peppermint lozenge oh my god
all right someone's like why they
brought the toys someone's like take the
german word out it's not just peppermint
it's all types of fruity candy and put
it in
santa's throat i don't even think they
make the peppermint flavor anymore 1927.
do they still make what are the flavors
of pez right now pez was invented in
austria in 1927 but the company's only
factory
and headquarters are located in orange
connecticut
it's owned by the haas family i think
the haas family dabbles in like easter
candy yeah
it's haas right it's gotta be this who
are descended from the inventor of the
candy edward haas the third
it's gotta be the same it's gotta be the
easter egg this is fun this is fun uh
pimpy
five things you didn't know about the
pez dispenser it's got to be the east
it's got to be the peeps houses right
those are the same people it's gotta be
pasta's peeps it's gotta be the same
houses
there are five things you might not know
about pez one
requests for personal pes heads are made
every day
the company turns them down a kim
kardashian dispenser request
was recently given the thumbs down and
you know if kim ain't getting one
good luck santa claus is the highest
selling pez dispenser
since its creation in 1951 wow i can see
that
the most expensive pez dispenser sold
for 13
000 was a political donkey made in 1961
only two
ever were made two only were made wow
there's a lot of political donkeys out
there today they won't give kardashian
one they're making two donkeys
[Laughter]
like get back to us kim k when you're a
political donkey yeah
all the pez distributed worldwide comes
from one factory in orange connecticut
it produces
12 million tablets of pes a day and uses
up to 50
000 pounds of sugar every four days
over three billion pes are consumed each
year in the u.s
alone take that last one joe pez was
originally created with a peppermint
flavor
to get austrians to quit smoking oh my
god
the campaign proved to be quite
successful in austria however when pez
came to america in the early 1950s
people here had taste buds
i'll tell you i'll tell you another
thing you don't need pez austrians to
quit smoking because now you have lucy
dot co
let's lead into that okay we're back all
right
uh so it's starbucks look i'm a fan of
pez but they're not the greatest kids
it's going to be sour patch kids versus
skittles
that's what it's going to be yeah that's
what we have i'm taking skittles
i also would love to know let's now
let's because you love to yell at me
about it
you love to yell at me about it are you
sticking with the traditional rainbow
flavors of snacks
i think you're allowed to do your breath
versus the breath of skittles versus the
breath of sour patch kids
there is no breath of sour patch kids
there's not more than one sour patch
i don't think so is there you're
defending a candy of course there's got
to be i don't even i only get i'm sure
they do different versions
like just just like like just calm down
okay just calm down
please would you please i've never heard
oh sour patch kids with skittles in them
skittle flavor sour patch kids because
you need the help
what what okay i guess we're off and
running are you you dopey dope
sour patch kids extreme sound kids
salad match kids marshmallows sour patch
kids berries sour patch kids
lip gloss sour patch kids blue raspberry
sour patch
all right all right what do you want to
do no sour patch kids freeze
i only do it so i only get the original
i get the originals that's my that's my
thing but whatever we know there's
different flavors i don't have to stray
anywhere except skittles original if you
want to do that bring it on bring it on
come on you started already
come on keep it going let's give you a
little briefing skittles were first made
commercially in 1974 by a british
company they were first introduced in
north america in 1979
as an import confectionary in 1982
domestic production of skittles began in
the united states
so those things hit when i was six and
you best believe
they took me by stone okay i i the name
skittles seemingly comes from a game
called skittles
it is because of the shape of the candy
resembles that of an object used in the
game so that's the first strike against
skittles skittles had to take their name
as a play on something else which sour
patch kids did not have to do
all right all right dial it back all
right let's show it back
i'll i'll open this up right now and say
this right out of the gate
i like skittles what did you have to you
had to you had to
suck the teat of the cabbage patch kid
is that what it is
what do you mean the sour patch kid yeah
playing on caps
of a cabbage pad you you took the they
took the
most famous and popular toy in the world
that year
those few years yeah and they they they
they rode the wave yeah and you're
saying skittles
i was making a joke i know but that was
that you needed all the help you can get
yeah
in 1985 by the way sounds like a skittle
sounds like a game you play
that gets you banned from schoolyards
yeah in 1985
sour patch kids rebranded to sour patch
kids
to capitalize off the popularity of
xavier roberts
i know i was capturing a joke like they
they didn't do that let's go let's talk
about the history read about your
history
originally created by frank however you
say it of jared international
under the name of mars men in the early
1970s
in the late 1970s cadbury great company
even though i don't like their food and
the samira blight and licorice company
of sweden
impressive formed the allen candy
company in hamilton ontario canada to
produce them
so here we are late 70s okay has here's
if i may start off with an opening
sentence and i miss when they had that
cover on them
when they had the cover of the kid that
kind of looked like a kid
a cabbage patch kid a little bit putting
his tongue out you need all the help you
can get okay can i can i just
can i make an opening just an open an
opening statement
yeah i've been asking you to do for 10
minutes you're great rambling on and on
okay spit it out opening statement is
sour patch kid
sucks oh yeah why is that
why is that because you can't handle it
it just sucks because it's too intense
why do i want to overcome a candy in
order to enjoy it you don't need to
overcome it
nobody does that when they put them in
their mouth nobody does that
no stop it oh that was a wild ride
no nobody does that yeah everyone puts
them in they pucker and
ice pops they got ice creams these
things are in everything so
you're chopping on lemons in your spare
time as well oh stop it
sour patch kids are delicious this is
just an easy thing skittles you know
what
it's sour it's the rainbow
tell me a better slogan for a candy okay
the rainbow is the best thing ever it's
a beautiful thing a rainbow roy g
biv it's all the colors it's amazing red
orange yellow green blue
if everything indigo violet
right taste it don't you want to taste a
rainbow
and that's the slogan and it's one of
the best slogans of all time it's a
great slogan nobody said
you look look at a bowl of skittles and
i almost i
you'd have to put you'd have to tie me
down for me to not just slam my head
into a bowl of skittles like an ostrich
into
the dirt but it's so appealing the color
palette of a bowl of skittles is so
appealing
it beckons you it beckons you to taste
it's
bursting with fruit flavor it's a
rainbow i want to taste it
i hope i'm and i don't like lime
skittles i usually
don't like the green gum dums the green
you know sour apple candies i don't like
apple
or lime i should say lime not apple lime
but i'll even take like a lot like the
rest of the skittles are so strong
that i can i'll accept the lime but you
got lemon
you got lime you got grape you got
cherry you got
orange there if you could for a second
you know what sour pasta you could for a
second
if you could for a second and i promise
you you can't
and man do i wish we had a bag of
skittles here
and if sal would for once
respond to my messages that i send four
days before we record saying let's pick
the topics
maybe we could but anyway i like to go
off the dome with my arguments
you want four days of prep work like at
marsha clark i'll give you this
i'll tell you this right now and and i i
promise you you couldn't do it
if you could blindfold it tell me the
difference between one skittle to the
next i'd be amazed
you could never are you a lunatic they
all taste the same no they don't they
all taste no they don't
i will we will pause this i will go to
the gas station we will get skittles and
sour patches we will come back
this is one of the ones you challenge me
that i think i shall taste it and i
shall prove you wrong
you don't think i could taste the
difference between cherry and grape
there is no way
lemon lime is the difference between
skittles you're crazy
and you can you discern between sour
patch kids no because they're all one
i didn't say i could i said if you're
gonna make that argument with skittles
i think skittles and sour patch kids all
of them taste the same
candy in and of itself inherently is
based on sugar
sugar is sweet to become to bring sour
into a candy
goes against the very fabric of what a
candy's supposed to be
you see you lying sack of garbage
skittles have different fragrances in
different colors but all
taste exactly the same skittles may be
one of america's favorite non-chocolate
candies but in 2018
skittles and its fellow candy haribo
gummy were put in the middle of a
controversy over flavors
thanks to neuroscientist dan katz who
claimed
i should have let you i should have been
blindfolded i should have let you taste
it blindfold it so you could have fell
on your face on this thing
i can't believe i didn't take you up on
that
his subjects were correct half the time
they
don't have different tastes this is how
we know they don't have different tastes
hold on do you think that the sour patch
kid is any different if that's true
i didn't say it was i didn't say it was
what i'm saying to you is just don't
come at me with the argument that
skittles have different flavors because
they don't well he said that they
plugged their nose up
this is and it says means you actually
have no idea this is how we know they
don't have different types well lemon's
gonna smell like lemon and trigger my
brain to think i'm tasting lemons
taste that's not different taste yeah
but i can i watch it
i smell i i spray i sprayed lemon lysol
in my bathroom
it doesn't mean that if i ate poop i
would think it was lemon
i don't know i'll leave yeah i'm gonna
leave it alone no you know i'll leave it
alone no you know because i
didn't just come from bellevue you know
so i'm gonna leave that one alone
because the minute i the minute i engage
him in this i become him
no you know this episode
one of our sponsors here is blue chew
stay with us
[Music]
blue chew is making waves and bringing
more confidence into the bedroom by
offering chewable tablets that can help
men get stronger
and longer lasting erections which is
the point
blue chew is a unique online service
delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra seals but in a
chewable form at a fraction of
the cost don't like swallowing pills no
problem here yeah
and i actually have a personal anecdote
i've used blue chew
okay i was in vegas for three days okay
going hard
partying okay partying had a very lovely
lady friend
okay who i met towards the end of the
run all right she said you know i know
we just met
i'd love for you to stay an extra night
and hang out my body's going
it's been blackjack and booze for three
days straight it's time to go home
yeah baby i popped a blue chew all right
and then you stayed an extra day in
vegas
and then you guys did stuff that adults
do behind closed doors with confidence
the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of our
licensed medical providers that they
have
and once you're approved that's it
you'll receive a prescription within
days the best part it's all done online
it's discreet it is affordable let me
tell you the deal that you get with
bluetooth.com with us
you're gonna get bluechew for free when
you use promo code tastebuds at checkout
just pay five bucks for the shipping
that's bluechew.com use promo code
tastebuds and you're going to receive
your first month
for free just pay the five bucks
shipping we thank you bluechu for
sponsoring the podcast
sal joe you listen to a lot of music
don't you i do
i do too and i want to talk about
some great earbuds because i'm tired of
paying tons of money for my earbuds
and then i go yeah however
raycon earbuds i'm going eh
and there's something we know about it's
buds isn't it that's right buddy
these earbuds that raycon is giving i
mean they're they're
so affordably priced they're such high
quality
they sink immediately with your phone
which i love
there's no ridiculousness in trying to
get them hooked up or to get them to
work or anything and they're built to
last they are
they're built to perform anywhere in any
time meaning that they are water and
sweat
resistant construction and the bluetooth
that you said seamlessly because i i
will tell you something i
i had buds in the past and i can sit
there over and over trying to sync
and i have to disconnect and sync and
they're dropping and then not
and this takes all of that out of it and
the best part is raycon makes great
sound accessible to
everyone that's important these days you
know the audacity is some of these
earbuds
out there you know like oh can you
afford
us are you part of our click raycon is
making them affordable for everybody
these wireless earbuds are starting at
half the price of other premium
audio brands so correct me if i'm wrong
they're already starting at half price
and raycon is offering 15 off of
all of their products for our listeners
if you go to
buy raycon dot com slash taste buds
that's it you'll get 15
off your entire order from raycon feel
free to grab a pair
that's it it's 15 off at buy rate recon
dot com slash taste buds
grab a pair and despair earbuds taste
buds
so let's take a break and i want to talk
about hair
please by the way i love you girls thank
you um
i have a lot of friends who are 35
maybe approaching 40 who are already
dealing with hair loss
i never knew that it happened at that
young age they want to pump the brakes
they're trying all kinds of different
things nothing's working
which is why i'm happy we can talk to
them and all of you
who may need this about keeps keeps is a
simple stress-free way
to keep your hair hence the name uh
convenient
virtual doctor consultations and
medications that are delivered straight
to your door every three months
so you don't have to leave your home
sure low cost yep
treatments are starting at just ten
dollars per month um
it comes in discrete packaging there are
proven results it has more five-star
reviews than any of its competitors
prevention is key and that's what keeps
us about right so treatments can take
four to six months to see results
so act fast this is going to help you
gonna keep what you got
yeah exactly what's you're gonna you're
gonna slow that
that fallout process and hopefully keep
as much of your hair as you possibly can
uh if you're ready to take the action to
prevent hair loss
go to keeps that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash taste buds to receive your
first month of treatment for free
k-e-e-p-s dot slash
taste buds to get your first month free
just so i understand it's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash taste buds to get your
first
month of treatment for free that's right
you can't say smell differentiates the
the knowing the difference between with
anything but listen i've been watching
i've
i'm not ashamed to say it i've been
going hog wild on episodes of hell's
kitchen
uh they have all like 20 seasons on hulu
now you want to talk to me about how's
kitchen but then what they do is he puts
on headphones
and he makes them do taste blind taste
tests
and chefs with amazing palates get [ __ ]
wrong
so i don't really care if you're gonna
plug my nose and ears and eyes and
throw eight skills in my mouth and i
can't tell you the difference between a
lemon and a lime
i think when i'm looking at them and i'm
not blindfolded and my nose isn't
clipped
i can't wait then that's a very
different argument
okay first of all let's just start with
the name skittles probably the best name
for them
guess what then guess what guess what
they guess what if you're gonna make
that scent that scent argument for
different flavors they go ah
when i see a yellow sour patch kid it
convinces me it tastes like lemon so i'm
just gonna go with that you know you
know there is no yellow sour patch kid
we're looking at them no there is none
we just saw this there's no
lemon-flavored sour patch kids there's
not
what else what are the fl what flavor is
the sour patch kids to you please pull
up a picture of sour patch kids
there's a yellow one on the front of the
frigging bag right there there's a
yellow one there's not a yellow flavor
you didn't listen to what i'm saying
you're not getting what i'm saying
listen to whatever every sour patch kid
is the same listen to what i'm saying
i'm saying if you're going with the
argument
that this that uh that uh oh look they
all have different flavors
uh no no no no they all taste sour but
you're not
sal you're you're not hearing what my
point is my point is not that
i'm saying if you're gonna make the
argument that you can trick your brain
into understanding the different flavors
of a skittle
then i can make that argument about sour
patch kids too and just go
oh well for you it's scent for me it's
color my brain thinks lemon so i taste
lemon but every sour patch kid that you
put into your mouth
is just gonna every skittle that you put
into your mouth tastes like plug your
nose they all taste exactly the same
fine whatever you want to say okay i'd
rather taste the fruit flavors of
skittles
bursting with fruit flavor taste the
rainbow then put
gummy gummy gelatins in my mouth that
tastes
purely sour they don't taste purely
shower power
every single sugar and sour it's they
they're coated in
sugar sour taste no matter what you put
in your mouth until you
get over it you have to beat the sour
that's not true
to finally get to the candy you get a
you get a sugar
and uh you get a sugar sweet and sour
flavor
immediately with sour patch kids the
sour then fades into the into the fruit
flavor of the gummy
and then you're done it's a wonderful
wonderful candy
the entire sour interaction is a
horrible
interaction it's huge no it's not
pleasant to you to most
no oh really yep you do which people
want money never saw a skittle store
we'll come back to that google skills
store let's just see it never saw a
scheduled
skittles store never saw a skill square
yeah let's see
nope no go back to the main pages there
like that was a map
eminem world hold on skittles no
oh you're under somebody else's roof bub
who has more uh who has more twitter
followers skittles or sour patch kids
pimp
let's check let's check but i'll make
the same argument here
that i made with oreos and and and uh
chips ahoy
there's a skittles flavored sour patch
kids because sour patch kids is inviting
your lesser candy into its head that's a
[ __ ] thing there would
never be a sour patch flavored skittles
okay skittles has 460 000 twitter
followers
sour patch kids has 75 000 maybe it's a
newer account tell you maybe it's a
newer account
uh sour patch kids joined march 2010
okay
skittles joined january 2010
so you're right they have two extra
months where they got that extra 380 000
followers your account is younger oh no
no you're right i'm wrong i'm sorry i
don't know
okay here's the thing buddy nope i don't
want to take my hard-earned money
and be like i'll give you currency can
you give me back
what tastes kind of like poison and
my body all my taste buds you talk about
taste buds your taste buds
reject every bit of sour patch kids
encompass almost every aspect of the
taste bud
it talk it goes to sour it goes to sweet
okay a texture okay
you know why you like sour patch kids
you want to know why you like sour patch
kids
you want a candy that matches your
attitude
they're delicious they're delicious
they're purposefully designed to taste
sour before tasting sweet
i actually think that you get a little
bit of that sugar thing right off the
bat
the sour part is so unpleasant
if i if i you have argued on behalf of
grapefruit on this podcast
no i didn't i argued that it was the
worst juice ever
no no
[Music]
stop stop stop let's not get off let's
not ruin the episode
because maybe it airs before this we
don't know we're not saying anything
that's just an episode that's coming up
here's my point
you all right um did you not argue about
eating a half a grapefruit in the
morning
no i didn't i said you said you did all
right then i look well i like it
don't call me names i said silly there's
no name for silly's not a name there's
no need for names
eating sour foods triggers a response in
the taste buds
which release chemical compounds and
then send a message to the brain
there serotonin a mood regulating
compound that also aids in the appetite
and sleep
is released why is salad is my main
man today dude he has given me so many
great
facts there's a good reason for this in
general kids really do
prefer sour taste much more than adults
do
so the hell's that we're talking about
candy sorry that kids love
my candy more so you joe you pick sour
patch kids i'll tell you right now i
love them
half the people and by the way they are
the only
sour candy on the planet no other sour
candy comes
close they are the you keep them i don't
care who dabbles in sour candy
i never want to put sour other than
cream
keep sour away from me sour means bad
sour grapes sour milk sour attitude of
skittles works a lot better than a bowl
of sour patch kids
you're going to have some melting issues
works a lot better there is no
bowl of sour patches don't even put them
in you can't
have a hard candy shell you can put them
in your pocket and eat them loose you
have to worry about stuff
there we go here we go you can eat them
loose you can shake them in your hands
here we go we're back to south pocket
food yeah okay go ahead put them in your
pocket
you you put your hand on a sour patch
kid you're getting all that disgusting
confectionary sour sugar sticky all over
you
the gel you can't put sour patch kids in
your pocket
you can't you don't you can't have your
kids on a hot day
to put loose candy in your pocket well
it's funny what's the matter with you
loose candies is what is the matter with
you if you've never had loose candy
you put the weird kid on the bus it's
literally a joke at the end of ferris
bueller when that weird girl goes
yeah i know i'm joking joe but if you
put a bag of
a bag of salad patch kids in your pocket
them shits is getting melty
and that's not true i've done it
it's still feeling you want to know what
happens but if it's hot you put it in
your mouth it breaks the line
i don't know what happens with a skittle
you know about a hot
that's when you're getting sweaty hands
and you're doing that but if you if your
siblings get a little heated and you put
them in and then you bite
the the center of the skittle i guess
people that have sweaty hands can't ever
eat skittles
cold skittle and then use it as a
sucking treat you don't
chew on it you don't you don't chew on
an ice cold skittle
until it breaks down from the heat in
your mouth and then you chew it
so there's this whole like thawing
process of a way you could eat a skittle
i like when i have a what's wrong with
you sour patch kids
what is it sticky jelly mess wrong with
you
orally why do you always want to suck on
foods
and let them roll around in your mouth
what do you mean it sounds almost
converted that is why we evolved
to have the mouths we have it's why we
have a podcast called taste
buds that's why i roll it around i'm a
connoisseur of all things
okay all right all right at the private
label brands starburst and sour patch
kids were the next
highest selling brands private brands
nearly
private brands nearly matched skittle
sales
of 183 million dollars
while starburst and sour patch kids
brought in 162 million
and 122 million respectively so we're
dealing in a powerhouse with powerhouse
products here this is as of 2020. so
there's only a 20 million dollar gap in
sales between because i was going to
maybe go against you at starburst
but in the end i think skittles are a
little more snackable
and the name is better but starburst is
up there i honestly
can't believe sour patch kids is this
popular i can't
i think what you're going to do the
greatest people in the world twitter
polls they're going to look at it and
they're either going to be
forward or dismiss it so you're going to
it's a polarizing candy whereas i think
more people
are going to have a similar viewpoint on
skittles where i like them you know
i like them some people will be like but
we'll be adverse to sour
you know and that's why i think it's a
silly thing to pick i think you would've
had a better chance going up against
they're my
first i'm not picking them to be
different i'm picking them because
they're my favorite candy
i think they're the best candy you're
you're you are a sour patch kid you
you've already done that
you already said it no i said i said sal
it matches your attitude you already
said but you are you could be
you could be on that could be your face
on that because it's too early to
retweet
can someone can somebody please
photoshop
the original face off the sour patch
kids and put joey's face on there i
would love that i would love a t-shirt
of that
uh all right
all right let's read some tweets let's
read some tweets three words
taste the rainbow told you simply
magical
sour patch kids are like having two
candies in one thank you colleen
i mean sour patch kids are okay i'm not
a huge fan of certain flavors in the
original skittles
but i certainly i likes i like
certain varieties we didn't get we
didn't we didn't go to other varieties
it would have been too much
this lunatic is saying that she likes
wild berries skittles
who the hell picks wild berries
they're good but i all i needed to win
to beat you was original skittles
so i kept it there all right i kept it
there all right i had no disrespect but
that's if you chose
oh if you chose sour patch kids you're
either living in an apartment with a
hole in the wall
two jaden smith tattoos on your thighs
and a dead fish in your freezer or a
psychopath
there is no other option well he's
describing you yeah wait what are you
talking about
he's describing you skittles are great
if you want to break a tooth or give
your jaw a massive workout
i didn't even think of that the hardness
of skittles
that's a great point the hardness is
good they will hurt your teeth if you're
not ready i just sour patch
just a wonderful song i took the hard
skittle
as a plus in what i just said i said
sometimes when they're a little too hard
you get to just chew on them like a
sucking treat sour patch
sour patch kids hold on go back sour
patch kids every day
of the week and twice on fridays thank
you nobody asked you about twice on
friday well
the sour patch kids commercials were the
exact
were they exactly like little gummy
jerks no were they at
the sauerkraut commercials where they
act like little gummy jerk-offs is the
perfect representation of a trash candy
skittles for life
yes that's our contestant so thank you
so far for winter
sour patch kids all day every day they
have two very good flavors of sweet and
sour in the candy along with
different flavors of colors different
flavors of colors
blue is the best sour patch kids let me
read one skittles could never
and will never yeah okay let me read one
that goes against you but they think
they're doing it a favor but it doesn't
once you start eating sour patch you
can't stop even after
all your taste buds are good because
it'll shred your tomatoes
and it'll whip your taste buds into a
coma you see how they capitalize taste
buds so they could work the name of the
show and that's all that is
that's all that is sour patch kids
because you don't need teeth to eat them
oh i'm killing over here i might win
this scroll can't believe i might win
this this is [ __ ]
skittles leave me with pain in my
stomach and i'd rather have that
every day than that poor excuse for a
gummy bear
that's the winner so far that's great
thank you very funny
to my knowledge no one has ever created
a portrait of steven tyler out of sour
patch kids
just saying skittles art wow that really
looks like him
but i wouldn't know who that is
okay sour patch kids are good for one or
two buddy brian lynch here we go
and then you're good for sour patch kids
for a while get out of here with that
novelty candy might as well ask for
skittle might as well ask skittles or
candy cigarettes i agree with you brian
he's saying you could have two and then
you have to be done it's too much
it's just too much to be honest this is
a tough one but i'd say skittles because
it always satisfies a sugar craving sour
patch kids are awesome but i don't
always want something sour tough
decision to make but i would
but at least i won't disagree with
whatever team you're on these suck asses
these suck asses yeah but the votes have
to be it now so it doesn't matter if we
have skittles hurt your teeth they are
always harder than stones all right
let's go to the boat
we got our winner for best tweet who was
it again
uh uh there it is right there uh our
winner beginner bots lol you can follow
them at beginner
bots lol skittles leave me with pain in
my stomach
and i'd rather have that every day than
that poor excuse for a gummy bear
that's very funny all right it is true
and i think i should have argued a
little bit more here but
sour patch kids is also not only roofing
or ripping off cabbage patch kids
but it's ripping off gummy bears i mean
gummy bears oh no it's coming don't stop
it is the
ultimate fruity gummy candy if i did
gummy bears versus that i thought it was
just
i thought it was too similar because the
only thing the only thing that sour
patch kids did
is they threw sour onto gummy bears no
and they called them children they are
not
yeah they did they are not gummy bears
they are not gummy bears
everybody sour patch kids sour patch
kids are like those what are those uh
those like uh those those round disc
fruit candies uh i want to say chickels
or or
chuckles chuckles it's that kind of
gummy it is not like gummy bear gummy at
all it is nowhere near the same thing
don't you dare
okay so you threw sour on a chuckle uh
pretty good to me you threw sour on a
chocolate looks delicious doesn't it
i i i just think it's a real all right
let's go okay so
you guys haven't brought up sour
skittles yet
listen to me skittles has a hundred
flavors
and they give you a variety and you can
get sour if you want them but i'm
arguing
my original skittles sour patch kids
only offers you sour
sour sour sour sour sour it's in the
name it's sour
who loves can we go to the
vote i'm sick of hearing your voice
let's let's
[Laughter]
let's take a look at your third-rate
gummy bear
thank you thank you
and by a much narrower margin 80 000
votes
52.9 to 47.1 wow
skittle sounds the rainbow show stick
your tongue out stick your tongue out
like a rainbow
stick your tongue out like the rainbow
admit something that i had the decency
to admit before
that by a much narrower margin than you
thought i can't believe it was this
close because yeah i don't think people
like sour patch kids
that's incredibly narrow margin i can't
believe what part of they have their own
store are you not understanding i can't
they have their own stuff
they're popular i might not understand
the popularity of this
one of the it's sour bench kids are one
of the five candies at the movie theater
they're it's skittles sour patch kids
twizzlers
uh raisinettes they're they're right
there man it's like
you know it never took for me so maybe i
don't realize their their reach how far
their reach is
but i can't believe that you were that
close because i can't eat it
i can't believe those might be the
number one like arguably the number one
powerhouse candy of all time and i feel
like salary everybody who doesn't like a
sour taste
is going to go against you the fact that
it stayed within under three percent
is telling to me i will give you that i
will give you that but
you took an l you took an l to skittles
the way i see it
everybody takes an l sometimes
all right wrap it up i still
i still love you babe i still love you
too that's our show folks thanks for
tuning in subscribe to the youtube
channel
got one that's a win give us a like when
you can leave a review on the podcast uh
page on itunes if you could the no
pressure network on
youtube follow that the no pressure
network on tick tock follow that
at taste buds pod on instagram and
twitter
new episodes every monday at 11 tell
friends that's the way we're going to do
this tell tell friends
you know and then follow and rate us and
also audio we always say that but
uh the numbers have jumped significantly
recently on spotify and itunes
so if you're listening on the audio
please give us a like and and
and a rating um and yeah that's that's
that's about it
skittles taste the rainbow taste buds
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
taste buds if you don't want your purse
they'll take your pay stubs
taste buds taste buds put on your boots
make sure they're laced up
what does that have to do with it
you